Both Sass and Auto-prefixer have
existing gulp plugins that we can use.
So, let's install them
as project dependencies.
Execute npm install
gulp-sass in your terminal,
which will install the plugin so,
we can use it in our gulp file.
Now we have to change the folder
structure slightly to account for
the generated CSS output files.
Create a new folder in your project
directory and call it sass.
Then move the files main.css and
extra.css from the CSS
folder into the sass folder.
And rename the extension to .XCSS.
We just turned them into Sass files
that soon got complied into CSS
files without a new task.
It is now an empty CSS directory.
Okay, before we can use
the gulp-sass plugin,
we need to make it available to gulp.
This works exactly as expected.
Just required as dependency
right of the Gulp.
Moving on, we create a new task and
named it styles,
which is what the first argument is for.
The second function as previously
is executed when a task is called.
Now, we just need to tell a gulp
what files we want it to work with.
For that, gulp has a special command
called source on the gulp object.
The line I just added looks for
files with the .css extension in a sass
folder at any potential sub-directories.
Now that we have the files,
we piped into Sass.
The pipe function on the stream
of files, we just created,
takes the destination that the plug
provides, so we call sass right here.
The good news is that we have converted
our files from Sass to proper CSS now,
the bad news is that we
haven't saved them anywhere.
So finally, we use pipe again, and
use the gulp.dest function to specify
our final destination, the CSS folder.
This is all we have to
do to make it work.
But by default,
the whole bit with stop and
error out when Sass discovers an error.
That's not always what you want.
Very often, it's better to finish and
actually that you see
what error happened.
Many plugins such like gulp-sass
emit events for this scenario.
Listening to the error
event on a Sass object and
inserting the sass log error function
here, changes the default behavior.
Instead of killing the whole build, it
tells Gulp to simply log the error and
go on as usual.
This looks much better.
Now, let's remove the CSS error and
try running Gulp in the terminal.
See how the CSS files came
back into your CSS folder.
These are generated from
the original Sass files.
Now will be a great time to get familiar
with Sass if you haven't already.
Just to give you an example, I can now
go ahead and nest my CSS to clean it up.
First mission accomplished.